[Musik]
gutes geld für gute lebensmittel
bundeskanzlerin merkel fordert faire
beziehungen zwischen landwirten und
handeln umstrittene medikamenten
lotterie ein pharmakonzern verlost
millionen teure therapien für todkranke
kleinkinder
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten amt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
montag an meiner seite ist für den sport
rudi cerne hallo guten amt es ist ein
thema das uns alle angeht was dürfen was
müssen lebensmittel kosten
und was ist nötig damit landwirte faire
preise für ihre produkte bekommen
darum ging es heute im kanzleramt bei
einem krisentreffen mit dem handel
allein vier handelsketten kontrollieren
zusammen mehr als 85 prozent des
lebensmittelmarktes sie haben also eine
mächtige verhandlungsposition auch wenn
es um preise geht zum beispiel bei der
milch sie kostet heute genauso viel wie
2012 der durchschnittslohn ist in der
gleichen zeit deutlich gestiegen
das freut verbraucher bringt aber
landwirte auf die barrikaden
elisabeth schmidt berichtet das kilo
äpfel für einen euro 19 ein kilo
schweinefleisch für nicht mal drei euro
billigangebote der supermarktketten
davon könne kein landwirt leben sagt
schweinehalter jan ehlers gehören ist
immer dass wir wertgeschätzt werden und
dass unsere produkte für wertgeschätzt
werden letztendlich zahlt sich ein berg
aber auch an der summe aus die wir dafür
bekommen so fallen laut deutschem
bauernverband von einem durchschnitts
kotelett 200 gramm gerade einmal 21 cent
für einen landwirt ab 18 cent pro kilo
brot schärfere umweltauflagen erschweren
bauern profitabel zu wirtschaften heißt
es auch heute wieder bei einer
demonstration vor dem kanzleramt
doch der handel sieht sich nicht in der
pflicht landwirte lieferten oft nicht
mal die hälfte ihrer produkte an
deutsche supermärkte landwirte sind
heute von globalen weltmarktpreisen
abhängig wenn 50 prozent des fleisches
exportiert wird dann bestimmen andere
die preise krisentreffen in berlin und
die kanzlerin brems zu beginn gleich
alle hoffnungen auf staatliche
preisvorgaben
insofern geht es auch hier nicht darum
irgendwelche staatlich verordneten
mindestpreise ihnen auch zu oktroyieren
wie ich manchmal gelesen habe sondern es
geht um faire um faire beziehungen
zwischen den verschiedenen akteuren die
bundesregierung will den handel weiter
zur fairen preisen drängen vier große
supermarkt player gegen tausende
landwirtschaftliche betriebe bloße
appelle von seiten der politik gingen an
der wirklichkeit vorbei sagen
handelsexperten der naheliegende versuch
die verhandlungsposition der landwirte
zu stark über muss nicht gesetzlich
machen kann oder will wäre natürlich
zusammenschlüsse der landwirte zu
fördern keine staatlichen preisvorgaben
vage versprechen der kanzlerin im streit
um billigpreise ist keine schnelle
lösung in sicht nach syrien wo die
militärischen auseinandersetzungen um
idlib zu nehmen
regierungstruppen die von russland
unterstützt werden haben türkische
stellungen im rebellengebiet angegriffen
heute nun der gegenangriff die türkei
spricht von 76 außer gefecht gesetzten
syrischen soldaten nach fast neun jahren
bürgerkrieg ist klipp das letzte gebiet
in syrien in das sich radikal-islamische
milizen zurückgezogen haben
über die anhaltende gewalt berichtet uli
gack bilder dieses krieges kaum zu
ertragen seit neun jahren schon
sie wollten vor kampfhandlungen flüchten
als ihr minibus von mutmaßlich
russischen oder syrischen jets getroffen
wurde heißt es hier
sieben zivilisten sind tod darunter drei
kinder
390.000 menschen soll die un sind in der
umkämpften provinz idlib irgendwohin auf
der flucht ins gebiete regierung wollen
und können viele nicht den weg ins
ausland hat die türkei geschlossen ein
einziger albtraum
nur gott weiß wohin uns der weg führt
wohl sein ziel ein haus liegt wir haben
keine ahnung
es ist diese taktik der verbrannten erde
die ganze städte in der provinz idlib im
trümmerhaufen verwandelt angewandt von
präsident assad und seinen russischen
unterstützen ebenso die von rebellen mit
türkischer hilfe oft sind krankenhäuser
erst das ziel von luftschlägen
durch die eingriffe in das hospital
nicht mehr betrieben werden viele
hilfskräfte sind ernsthaft verletzt die
gesamten nachbargebäude des
krankenhauses wurden zerstört
seit zwei wochen eskaliert der kampf um
etliche es ist wie immer in syrien die
regierung assad will mit luftschlägen
den sieg erzwingen die meist
islamistischen rebellen werden sich wohl
nicht ergeben ein land versinkt in
trümmern im november wählen die us
amerikaner einen neuen präsidenten
die große frage ist wer gegen donald
trump antritt den kandidaten der
republikaner
am abend steht bei den demokraten die
erste vorwahl an und zwar hier im
mittleren westen der usa im bundesstaat
iowa elf anwärter sind noch im rennen
umfragen sehen ein trio vor den linken
senator bernie sanders den moderaten ex
vize präsidenten joe biden und die linke
senatoren ines trams berichtet mehr
schweine als menschen gibt es in europa
knapp drei millionen einwohner leben
hier die meisten von ihnen weiß dennoch
hier wird der trend gesetzt wer soll für
die demokraten antreten ganz nahe bei
den menschen so sieht hier der wahlkampf
aus der ehemalige vizepräsident joe
biden liegt weit vorn in den umfragen
ein moderater demokrat der wie er sagt
zurück zur normalität will amerikas
seele stehe auf dem spiel
wir wählen hoffnung nicht angst
einigkeit stadt spaltung wir wählen
wahrheit nicht lügen
seine anhänger wollen weitere vier jahre
trump verhindern
sie halten beiden für den wählbaren
kandidaten für die demokraten
joe biden der netteste lustigste den ich
kenne klug es war die beste kombination
damals präsident obama und biden fast
gleichauf mit beiden bernie sanders er
will nicht zurück sondern amerika
umkrempeln leidenschaftlich seine
anhänger dass der selbsterklärte
sozialist wähler verschrecken lassen sie
nicht gelten wir haben keine zeit mehr
auf nummer sicher zu gehen
wir müssen das machen woran wir glauben
es geht um mehr als politik es geht um
eine revolution die demokraten in euro
war tun sich schwer mit ihrer
entscheidung rund 60 prozent noch immer
unentschieden
wer kann donald trump paroli bieten da
ist sicherlich eine gewisse angst sich
zu entscheiden wer würde am besten
aussehen
in einer tv-debatte mit diesem schon
hier in der hauptstadt von kovar werden
heute nacht die ergebnisse der ersten
vorwahl einlaufen
es ist der auftakt zum kampf um das
weisse haus in china verbreitet sich das
corona virus weiterhin schnell
mittlerweile haben sich dort nach
offiziellen angaben über 17.000 menschen
infiziert 360 sind gestorben
im rest der welt sind rund 180
infektionen mit dem virus bestätigt
davon zehn in deutschland also keine
neuen fälle bei uns auch nicht unter den
in einer kaserne in rheinland-pfalz
isolierten china heimkehren
wegen der lage in china hat die
lufthansa angekündigt ihre flüge dorthin
mindestens bis ende februar auszusetzen
je mehr sich das virus verbreitet desto
größer wird die angst und treibt
seltsame blüten in den sozialen
netzwerken häufen sich
verschwörungstheorien und
falschmeldungen
im realen leben werden menschen
diskriminiert die asiatisch sind oder
asiatisch aussehen
thomas concia berichtet geht hier ein
virus um das virus vorurteil frankfurt
römerberg asiatisch aussehende touristen
und einheimische nachdem krone ausbruch
ausgrenzung unterschiedliche erfahrungen
ich bin ein bisschen traurig gestern
wollte ich in ein restaurant
aber die haben wir gesagt wir wollen
keine chinesischen kunden negative
erlebnisse machen menschen mit
asiatischen wurzeln auch in weiteren
ländern etwa in frankreich sie wehren
sich tauschen sich aus zeigen gesicht
trieb am virus ich bin kein virus dieses
motto auf twitter hat marvin kohl
journalist bei einer berliner zeitung
nun nach deutschland geholt
es gab viele reaktionen die mehrheit
zuspruch gegeben haben dass sie auch so
etwas erlebt haben also eine kollegin
vom tagesspiegel hat halt erzählt dass
die leute sich in der bahn von ihr weg
gesetzt haben dass sie schräg angeguckt
wird dass sie auch gefragt wird ja wie
ist das denn so bei euch mit dem
bewohner virus obwohl die kollegin halt
seit mehr als 20 jahren in deutschland
lebt alle asiaten krank wenn fakten doch
sagen falsch warum lassen sich viele von
angst anstecken
dadurch dass jetzt mit einem virus
gleichgesetzt werden also der virus
selbst hat ja keine personifizierung
werden wir umso mehr ein mensch licht
und eine konsequenz seine politische
konsequenz daraus ist aggression und
durchaus auch gewalt damit es dazu nicht
kommt setzt marvin kohl darauf
miteinander zu reden dem virus angst
keine chance auch in deutschland sind
die wissenschaftler auf der suche nach
einem impfstoff gegen das corona virus
mehr dazu gleich im anschluss in visum
nach brüssel und london kaum ist der
wechsel vollzogen geht der eigentliche
verhandlungspoker los heute gab es einen
vorgeschmack wie hart das gerangel um
die künftigen beziehungen zwischen der
eu und großbritannien werden wird beide
seiten machten erst mal klar was sie
nicht wollen
gunnar krüger berichtet erste arbeitstag
nach dem rexit kein speck keine bohnen
uhr gutes kontinentales frühstück ursula
von der leyen und die briten in ihren
diensten sie behalten einfach den job
der rest wird komplizierter es gibt
keinen freifahrtschein zum binnenmarkt
rechte und pflichten müssen immer im
gleichgewicht stehen beispiel fischerei
großbritannien hat die fanggründe europa
die absatzmärkte zugang wollen beide
seiten zum jeweils anderen
doch boris johnson fordert kurz gefasst
das gegenteil mit blick auf zeiten als
sein land die meere beherrscht
ich sehe nicht die notwendigkeit dass
wir uns an ein abkommen mit der eu
linden
wir werden die souveränität über unsere
grenzen über migration wettbewerb statt
beihilfen und datenschutz
wiederherstellen
und doch wollen beide ab märz verhandeln
müssen schon im juli entscheiden ob sie
eine verlängerung wollen wenn nicht muss
im november ein abkommen stehen wenn
doch blieben ein bis zwei jahre mehr
zeit so oder so brüssels unterhändler
setzt dafür den ton
nach diesem wir sind verfechter des
freihandels aber wir sind nicht naiv
vor allem sei man etwa auf staus
vorbereitet sowie im hafen von rotterdam
liegen die no deal pläne noch immer in
der schublade
unser nächstes thema ist ein höchst
umstrittenes glücksspiel
es geht um das leben schwer kranker
kinder ein neues gentechnisch
hergestelltes medikament könnte ihnen
helfen
allerdings kostet ist 2 millionen euro
die firma novartis hat es entwickelt
gegen die spinale muskelatrophie ein
seltener muskelschwund die meisten der
kleinen erkrankten sterben nach wenigen
jahren
jetzt hat die firma eine weltweite
verlosung gestartet für 100 kleinkinder
zahlt novartis allein in deutschland
soll es aber jedes jahr 50 neue fälle
geben
anna basbug der kleine michael leidet
unter der schwersten form von
muskelschwund lebensbedrohlich nach
einer groß angelegten medienkampagne von
unterstützern hat die krankenkasse
letztes jahr schließlich die fast zwei
millionen euro teure spritze für ihn
gezahlt
es ist für uns ein großes wunder dass es
geklappt hat
dann kam der nächste runde dass er sich
dann gleich am dritten tag richtig
drehen konnte doch in deutschland ist
dieses medikament bisher nicht
zugelassen andere familien warten darauf
deshalb wählt novartis jetzt zweimal im
monat ein erkranktes kind auf der ganzen
welt per zufall aus und gibt ihm eine
gratis dosis globales härtefall programm
nennt das unternehmen dieses umstrittene
verfahren
wir haben einfach nicht so viele dosen
zur verfügung wie wir gerne hätten
bei aller kritik an diesem verfahren
mangelt es vorerst an vorschlägen für
bessere alternativen
auch krankenkassen und
gesundheitsbehörden scheint nichts
besseres ein zu fallen für die vergabe
noch nicht zugelassener teurer
medikamente die krankenkassen sagen sie
würden das medikament bezahlen wenn es
offiziell zugelassen wäre wir hätten uns
gewünscht dass es eine schnelle
zulassung kippt das heißt ein schneller
antrag dann hätten wir weder über ein
härtefall programm reden müssen noch
über diese sehr ethisch moralisch
fragwürdige variante
wird künftig immer mehr teure gegen
medikamente geben und damit auch die
frage ob das den finanziellen rahmen der
krankenkassen sprengt aber die gratis
vergabe per lotterie verfahren viele
medizinethiker halten das für eine
marketingkampagne des herstellers es ist
jedenfalls ein willkürliches verfahren
wo wir jetzt auf den hersteller
angewiesen sind dessen regeln folgen
müssen
also was die anzahl der patienten zum
beispiel an geht dies jetzt bekommen
sollen ist intransparent michael scheint
es besser zu gehen
die frage ist nur wie lange das
medikament tatsächlich wirkt das
ethische und medizinische für und wider
dieser umstrittenen verlosungen haben
wir auf heute.de noch einmal für sie
aufbereitet da zeigen wir auch je früher
babys das medikament erhalten um so
besser entwickeln sie sich mit einem
superlativ in den usa ist es das
sportliche highlight der super bowl das
endspiel der amerikanischen
football-liga das gewohnt spektakulär
inszeniert wird miami gewannen die
kansas city chiefs nach einer imposanten
aufholjagd gegen die san francisco vor
die niners mit 31 zu 20 der jubel bei
den fans riesengroß und er war der star
des spiels gestern abend in miami
patrick mayer holmes quarterback der
kansas city chiefs im letzten viertel
behielt er nach einem
zehn-punkte-rückstand die nerven und
führte die chips zum sieg nicht so gut
aber die jungs haben an mich geglaubt
und wir haben weitergekämpft und
schließlich einen weg gefunden zu
gewinnen die kansas fans im ganzen land
im siebten himmel
beim super bowl aber geht es um mehr als
sport und trophäen
er ist ein nationales großereignis bei
dem amerika zusammengekommen gut 100
millionen menschen im stadion und vor
dem fernseher sahen dann auch die
halbzeitshow mit den beiden latino stars
shakira und jennifer lopez die mit viel
nackter haut eine botschaft für das
gespaltene land hatten wir gehören auch
dazu amerika ist vielfalt
[Musik]
und weil mehr aufmerksamkeit in amerika
nicht geht wahlwerbung auch vom
präsidenten und einem seiner möglichen
herausforderer dem new yorker milliardär
mike bloomberg der sich in seinem spot
mit der waffenlobby anlegt rund elf
millionen dollar sollen jeder von ihnen
für 60 sekunden werbezeit während des
spiels bezahlt habe es war mal wieder
ein großes spektakel für team und fans
der kansas city chiefs aber war es noch
viel mehr
50 jahre hatten sie auf diesen moment
gewartet achtelfinale im dfb pokal in
dieser woche werder bremen will morgen
gegen dortmund einen schritt aus der
liga krise schaffen gar nicht so einfach
der bvb feiert zurzeit eine tor party
nach der anderen
konzentriertes training der
werder-profis einen tag vor dem
pokalkracher gegen dortmund in der liga
gab es zuletzt wenig zu lachen sechs
niederlagen aus den letzten sieben
spielen bedeuten platz 16 und
abstiegskampf pur
es ist natürlich so dass der pokal ja
auch immer wieder die möglichkeit gibt
gerade für mannschaften die aktuellen
nicht so gut in anderen wettbewerben
darstellen besondere highlights zu
setzen
es gilt vor allem dortmund spiellaune zu
bändigen zuletzt 15 tore in drei spielen
die beiden 19-jährigen offensivstars
sandstrahlern sind in überragender form
bekommt man die beiden in den griff so
die hoffnung könnte es etwas werden mit
der pokalsensation im weser-stadion hab
ja schon dicke überraschung in bukarest
batra wir haben wollen zum schluss
wollen wir ihnen noch zeigen wie ein
berliner künstler google ausgetrickst
hat und zwar so simon beckert läuft
durch berlin mit einem bollerwagen darin
99 smartphones auf allen ist die google
maps app aktiviert der kartendienst
erkennt die handys fälschlicherweise als
autos und aus einer leeren grünen straße
wird so schwuppdiwupps eine rote ein
virtueller stau der zeigt wie leicht
sich digitale dienste manipulieren
vorsicht beim wetter heute nacht zieht
ein orkantief über die mitte und den
süden es drohen überschwemmungen und
hochwasser
aktuell warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
vor dauerregen und tauwetter sowie
orkanböen in teilen baden württembergs
und bayerns die details hat gleich katja
honnefer im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn bringt sie marietta slomka auf den
neuesten stand
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen unbeschwerten abend und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren über
frankreich da braut sich bereits ein
orkantief zusammen das ist das orkantief
petra und das zieht bis morgen früh
weiter bis nach bayern
das bringt viel regen mit und das wird
gefährlich besonders im allgäu und im
schwarzwald da gab es ja auch tauwetter
es drohen also weitere überschwemmungen
und hochwasser
und dazu kommt nach dieser sehr starke
wind wir erwarten orkanböen also von
orkanstärke stärke 12 120 kilometer pro
stunde
nicht nur in den gipfellagen der alpen
sondern verbreitet hier im süden
deutschlands und das ist noch nicht
alles denn bis zum frühen morgen geht
der regen oberhalb von 500 metern schnee
über machen sie sich also darauf gefasst
dass sie morgen etwas länger für den weg
zur arbeit brauchen die temperaturen der
nacht liegen zwischen 7 und 0 grad und
ändern sich tagsüber kaum dann sind das
so zwischen 0 und 8 grad
das orkantief petra allerdings das zieht
morgen sehr rasch weiter nach osten und
danach gibt es noch jede menge schnee
regen und graupelschauer sind auch
gewitter dabei
und am freundlichsten wird es morgen
hier an der nordsee der wind dazu kommt
aus nordwestlichen richtungen und die
einzig gute nachricht heute ist ab
mittwoch beruhigt sich das wetter
deutlich schönen abend noch